this is session four of the foundations
and finance module and in this session
i'd like to talk about risk a concept
that drives our decision making in
finance
risk has always been around and for much
of human existence that risk was
physical risk
a cave person would not survive if he
did not take physical risks
but about 600 years ago you started to
see a separation between physical risk
and financial risk
and here's what i'm talking about i'm
talking about that wealthy
individual in england who put who bought
a ship
put sailors on the ship and sent them
off to the far east to get spices
if the ship came back in one piece
he became wealthy and if the ship did
not make it back either it
because it sunk or was attacked by
pirates the sailors were the ones who
died you saw
separation between physical risk and
financial risk
since that time though we've started to
see that separation
increase today when we talk about risk
and investing it's almost
never a physical risk it's a financial
risk
so here's the question i want to start
with what is risk
and my answer is don't play with words
what am i talking about
in the 1920s frank knight an economist
argued that
uncertainty was different from risk and
here's the distinction he drew
he said let's assume you have two
individuals drawing from an urn of red
and black balls and the first individual
doesn't know how many red balls and
black balls
there are in the urn he is uncertain the
second individual though
knows how many red and black balls there
are he is
taking risks because he can give you a
probability i don't like that
to me risk is risk whether you put a
number on it
or not is your choice but just because
you cannot put a
number on it doesn't mean that there's
no risk so with that
on as the basis let's go further to me a
good definition of risk
is one that captures the fact that it is
dual
dual in what sense risk can't just be
viewed as a negative
and here's why if risk is just a
negative
the way we should respond to risk is by
avoiding it right
so the best risk management strategies
would be risk avoidance strategies
and that's no way to build a business in
fact if you look at great businesses and
you think of
how they became great they became great
not by avoiding risk
but by seeking out risk not by seeking
at every risk but seeking out the right
kind of risk
to me that is the essence of risk
management to understand
that risk is both a positive and a
negative and
good risk-taking means that you're
weighing the trade-off
and you're taking those risks where the
good outweighs the bad you know
no guarantees but that's the essence of
risk-taking
so one of the first starting points for
risk is to redefine risk as both good
and bad
positive and negative now with that in
place
let's start off by understanding why we
think about risk so much in finance
as human beings we're risk averse you
see what are you talking about
let me try a simple experiment on you
let's suppose
i'm going to flip a coin and i'll pay
you a dollar if the coin comes up tails
on the first flip and i will pay you
nothing if it comes up heads
and i'm going to keep repeating this
experiment right so each time i flip
this coin
you should your expected value is 50
cents right
and it builds up over time if you take
this expected value and you build it
through
the expected value if i'm going to do
this an infinite number of times
should be infinite you are you willing
to pay an infinite amount for this set
of experiments where i'm going to keep
flipping a dollar if it comes up tails
i'll repeat it
and i'll keep going well think about it
i don't know what the answer you would
give us but this is the experiment that
nick bernoulli ran
i don't i don't know whether he went by
the name nicholas is perhaps
what he went by in the 1700s he wanted
to see
whether people would pay an infinite
amount of money because the expected
value of the series of outcomes is
infinite
he found on average that people paid
about two dollars to play the game
and he started asking why he basically
discovered
that in that people were risk wars
you're saying it took people that long
to figure it out
well he was the first one who made it
concrete he also noticed that the value
that people attached
was different for different people a
second big
uncovering that peop that risk aversion
varies across
individuals and the third thing he found
also
was that as people got wealthier
they seemed to be willing to pay more
that people got less risk averse as they
got wealthier
those are the building blocks for how we
think still think about risk aversion
in economics and finance in fact there
are two ways we measure risk aversion
the first is with what we call certainty
equivalence
that sounds fancy but let me give you a
very simple example
let's assume that i give you a 50 that i
give you
a bet 50 of the time you're going to
make a thousand dollars 50
of the time you're going to make nothing
and i ask you how much you'd be willing
to pay for that bet
the expected value of that bet is five
hundred dollars right
fifty percent times a thousand plus
fifty times perfect
the question i would ask is how much
would you accept as a
certainty equivalent as a guaranteed
amount instead of that expected value
if you said 500 you're risk neutral
because you're accepting the expected
value which is uncertain
if you said 400 your risk averse
if you said 300 you're even more
risk-averse it's called a certain
equivalent
and the more risk-averse you are the
less you will accept as a guaranteed
amount for that uncertainty expected
value
that's one way to think about risk
aversion the second in the nikon
economics we call these risk aversion
coefficients
is if i can define utility functions
this is the way i measure how happy you
are
those utility functions will have a
place in them for your risk aversion
and i can measure your risk aversion
with the risk aversion coefficient
much messier much more technical but it
comes from utility functions but they're
both
measures of risk aversion and they both
try to capture
how risk-averse you are now over the
last
decades we've had studies that looked at
differences in risk aversion across
people how risk-averse people are
and there are four sets of studies that
draw these conclusions
the first are experimental studies where
you take 15 20 25 people and you offer
them these choices to see what they
choose
and based on these controlled
experiments you make judgments about
risk aversion
the second are surveys where you ask
people how they deal with
risk in real the real world how much
insurance they buy what portfolio
choices they make
and you draw from those conclusions
about risk aversion
the third and this is one of my favorite
devices you look at what people pay for
risky assets stocks
bonds you're in a sense getting from the
price a measure of how risk-averse they
are
and finally there are if you go to
casinos you go to game shows you go to
the racetrack you're getting a measure
of how people
deal with risk almost on a
minute-by-minute basis by looking at
what they bet on and how much they're
willing to bet
now if you look at the collective
evidence from this risk aversion here's
what we seem to have uncovered
and i'm not claiming this as a
generalization but these are general
findings
when men are compared with women at
least these studies seem to find that
men are
less risk-aversed than women when it
comes to small bets
so survivor offer you a 50 bet on a game
men tend to be much more cavalier about
accepting small bets
but as the bets get larger men and women
seem to be about equally risk averse
young men are less risk averse than
young women but as
as people age men and women are about
equally risk averse
studies also have looked at does your
risk aversion increase or decrease as
you become more experienced
at a particular set of bets so for
instance
a study compared bids from naive
students people who'd never done this in
construction industry experts for
bidding on real estate and they found
that as
people became more experts more the more
expertise you had
the less risk averse you became
something to think about when you think
about traders out there
that traders as they trade longer and
longer actually become less risk of us
because they either learn more about the
market or
worse they think they've learned more
about the market
young versus old people no surprise here
young people
are less risk averse than older people
something to again keep in mind as you
watch the
aging of of japan and europe
perhaps that has something to say about
how how much risk aversion you're going
to see
both in product and financial markets
and finally when you compare across
races and cultures the evidence is
actually interesting because
contrary to conventional wisdom there
are no conservative cultures
it looks like risk aversion is about the
same across cultures across
races people are more alike than they're
different
now that said over the last few decades
especially in the last 35 to 40 years
the area of behavioral finance has found
that there are some quirks in the way we
take risks
the first is how you present a bet seems
to make a difference in how people react
to it let me give you an example
i said would you rather save 200 people
out of 600 people
or accept a one-third probability that
everybody will be saved
it's exactly the same thing
mathematically but while the two
statements are mathematically equivalent
more
people said they would prefer to save
200 out of 600 people
then accept a one-third probability that
everybody will be saved
here's the second choice would you
rather take 750 dollars or
75 chance of winning thousands that's an
easy one right because your risk averse
you say i'll take the 750 it's
guaranteed
let me change the question a little bit
would you rather lose 750 guaranteed
or have a 75 chance of losing a thousand
dollars
here it looks like all more people
prefer to have a 75
chance of losing a thousand rather than
a guaranteed loss
that's called loss version changing the
sign
seems to change the way we look at those
bets
then you have this notion of what's
called myopic loss aversion and what
that effectively means is
giving people more frequent feedback on
what's
happening to their bets and investments
seems to make them more risk-averse
something to keep in mind an age where
we get feedback continuously about
what's happening to our portfolios
here's something that shouldn't surprise
you people are more willing to take
big risky bets with other people's money
than with their own money with house
money
than with their own money and that's
basically something that comes from i
think within
so if you if i if you come into a casino
now i hand you money at the door even
though it's now your money
the fact that i handed you the money
rather than it being money that you
earned
makes a difference in how you bet with
that money
and finally here's an interesting
phenomenon when people
lose money on bets when they lose money
in casinos it
looks like they get less risk of us in
trying to get
back to break even in other words they
start taking bigger and bigger risks
just to get back to breakeven
something that every casino knows but
something to keep in mind
these are things that go against classic
economics in terms of risk aversion
but this is what behavioral finances
brought to the table
but in summary here's what we've learned
about
ourselves and risk aversion that we're
collectively risk-averse
that we're more so when we have big
stakes and we're small there are
differences in risk aversion across
groups of people males females here but
those differences are far smaller than
the
what we share in common there are quirks
in risk-taking behavior
were far more affected by losses than
equivalent gains that loss aversion
kicks in
and when presented with risky choices
the way we're presented those choices
seems to make a difference in whether we
take those choices we're more willing to
take risks with
found money house money and finally
there are two scenarios where we seem to
abandon risk aversion and become risky
one is
when we see a chance of making a huge
amount of money with a very small bet
okay that explains you know the reason
we take on
you know we buy lottery tickets and the
other is when you've lost money and
you're trying to get back to break even
we seem to abandon risk aversion
so keep that in mind as we start
developing risk models because this
might explain
why people behave the way they do and
sometimes why they behave strangely